welcome back while substance use
disorders and underlying trauma tend to
go hand in hand but Landmark recovery of
Las Vegas the sponsors of this segment
are working hard to help those in the
community who need addiction treatment
and here to tell us more is Teresa Sands
Teresa thank you so much for being here
thanks for having me this is a really
important conversation important things
that you're doing in the community but
let's jump right into it let's talk a
little bit about how substance abuse and
Trauma are really kind of intertwined
absolutely
so the substance use is of course a
Band-Aid for some underlying condition
whether that's trauma whether that is
you know past life of addiction
substance use genetics so substance use
disorder is both a genetic disposition
mixed in with an outside stressor so
something like trauma could trigger the
substance use disorder so when someone
comes into your treatment centers maybe
experiencing both what is kind of the
plan of attack for that and does that
kind of differ from other circumstances
well Landmark is a dual diagnosis
facility as you mentioned and the first
thing that we're going to do with the
client coming in the door is getting
them acclimated right making sure they
feel comfortable making sure their needs
are met and then aligning them with the
therapist that meshes with them that
understands our therapists are wonderful
they understand the disease they
understand you know what it takes to get
somebody to the other side as well as
the rest of the staff at Landmark and if
someone is watching at home right now
and thinking about themselves or a loved
one and they want to help them get
treatment what are some tips or advice
you have for them to just even get in
the door that's such a lot of question
but honestly the first thing to say to
somebody who's suffering from this
disease is that you're not alone I
myself am a person of long-term recovery
many of the people that work at Landmark
are also in long-term recovery or they
have strong recovery allies people that
they know friends family that offer
stuff from this disease the first first
thing is of course to be there for that
person not to shame them to break the
stigma there's no shame in asking for
help and there's never going to be the
right time to ask for help right it's
always going to be my job or my kids and
that small window you have in order to
take and put your health is a priority
it is just that so small and if you
don't put yourself first and put your
health first what do you really have
yeah well Teresa thank you so much for
opening up about this and your story and
I'm sure it's very rewarding to be able
to help those now in need and I just
want to mention here that on right here
on 8 news now we have an opioid special
running on April 29th from 8 to 9 pm
followed by a live Facebook q a for any
questions that you might have so this
will be very important for what every
family needs to know about Fentanyl and
it's just a really really important
conversation to have so Teresa thank you
so much for being here having this
conversation with us and all of the
information on your screen right there
thank you to Landmark recovery of Las
Vegas if you want to give them a call at
725-217-9910 or visit markrecovery.com
we'll be right back